le diep pour solissu poussé vers l'est
c'est civil évacue la ville de Kerson
impossible d'affirmer si la
contre-offensive ukrainienne ou l'ordre
d'évacuation donnée par les autorités
d'occupation russe et la cause de leur
départ
contre un tout nom une civil s'exprime à
la télévision d'État russe
il ne se souciont pas des personnes qui
mourront nous avons donc plié bagages et
sont devenus ici en conduisant je me
disais ça va c'est comme partir en
voyage nous ne sommes pas seuls d'autres
gens sont avec nous les autorités pro
russe prévoient de déplacer 50 à 60 000
civils dans les prochains jours
l'évacuation se poursuit afin de donner
à la population Pacifique une
opportunité de traverser le fleuve
jusqu'à la rive est de la région de
Kerson concernant les entrées de civil
dans la région celles-ci sont dorénavant
interdite selon ses autorités les
évacuations sont volontaires mais les
seules routes ouvertes mènent vers la
Russie Kiev dont les forces avancent
vers les rives du niepre dénoncent
l'utilisation des habitants à des fins
de propagande
les Russes essaient de faire peur aux
habitants de Kerson avec de fausses
informations sur le bombardement de la
ville par notre armée
Moscou affirme que 5 millions de
personnes ont déjà quitté les régions
ukrainiennes annexées direction la
Russie de son côté qui a fait sphère
reconquérir Kerson 300000 habitants
avant la guerre et ses importants sites
industrielles avant l'hiver